hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Captain America Civil War Easter
Egg video just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet they were a
whole bunch the Russos the people that
directed the movie lifelong comic book
fans so a lot of the Easter eggs are
direct visual or verbal references to
comic book things some of them are also
internal Easter eggs to the MCU for
things that have happened in previous
films and some of them are Easter eggs
for things that the Russos have done in
real life the first fun example just
started off is the Russos originally
directed an episode of community the
Dean from community was the Dean for MIT
the Tony Stark was speaking at where he
issued that big grant if you haven't
watched it in a while the episode that
they did was the Dungeons & Dragons
community episode probably one of the
best episodes of television ever later
when Tony Stark is trying to give the
pen to Captain America he calls it a
timely gift Marvel used to be called
timely comics before it became Marvel
Comics Stan Lee whose cameo you probably
recognized as the FedEx guy the Tony
State guy at the end of the movie
started working at Marvel during the
time when it was timely comics when
they're chasing after Brock rumlow
you will recognize him in his crossbones
uniform he becomes crossbones in the
comics you get to see Falcons new toy
Red Wing which is actually an Easter Egg
for Red Wing in the comics which is an
actual red Falcon when Captain America
tells Scarlet Witch just like we
practiced and she throws him into the
building that's their version of the
fastball special we're way back in the
x-men comics Colossus would pick
Wolverine up he'd pop his claws and he
just throw them at people which probably
reminds you of the assists later in the
movie at the airport battle we're gonna
be jumping back and forth in the
timeline where a man rides on the tip of
Hawkeye's boat that's from way back in
Avengers number 223 right on the cover
someone's gonna get it
giant man probably one of the coolest
reveals in the movie the first time that
ant-man turned into giant man it was
Hank Pym and it was during tales to
astonish number 49 way back in 1963 Hank
Pym said you can never trust a stark
that's an easter egg for the ant-man
movie there was a flashback scene where
Howard Stark was trying to get Hank Pym
Michael Douglas's character to join what
would then become the shield
organization which had already been
infiltrated by high
deep mistrust of government oversight
which is one of the reasons why he
picked Scott Lang to join Team ant-man
because of his mutual distrust of
authority which kind of explains why
ant-man is so teen Captain America
because Captain America when he and Iron
Man are first talking about their big
standoff the Easter Egg there when he
says I've seen things go sideways when
government's agendas change he's talking
about the Nazis in World War two
Hitler rising to power the Nazi agenda
another deep Easter Egg that they kind
of address in the movies it actually
goes all the way back to Iron Man 2 so
Tony says I've always hated you because
he kind of resents Captain America
because Howard Stark his father would
never shut up about him everybody has
daddy issues in the Marvel Universe but
there was an old home movie reel that
Tony was watching during Iron Man 2
where Howard Stark is speaking to him on
tape saying Tony you're my greatest
creation
so technically his dad wasn't more proud
of Captain America but that doesn't mean
that Iron Man still doesn't resent him
you definitely feel like Tony Stark
loathes himself just because of all the
terrible things that he's done and
speaking of which flashback scene this
is
80s Robert Downey jr. it doesn't look
perfect this doesn't look exactly like
he did in the 80s but it's very close
Robert Downey jr. called it very
expensive nostalgia just because that
type of CG is very expensive right now
but people do it all the time the scene
that he's in the scene that plays out of
him in the past
where he says you know thank you Dad I
love you you did the best you could and
then later you know when the adult Tony
Stark walks in and goes I wish it had
happened that way meaning that the last
time he saw his parents he probably said
something really shitty to them it's a
little bit like what happened the last
time spider-man talked to Uncle Ben so
you can kind of see parallels in the
backstory of spider-man and Iron Man so
you understand why Tony Stark might feel
a special connection to Peter Parker
young smart kid who lost both his
parents and now Uncle Ben so let's talk
a little bit about spider-man there's a
whole bunch of spider-man Easter eggs
the first time we see him he's wearing
that Pizza shirt if you remember
Spiderman was a pizza delivery man
during spider-man to the mechanical
web-shooters
also an Easter Egg for the comics the
story behind the organic web shooters is
actually kind of funny James Cameron was
originally supposed to do a spider-man
film way way back in the 90s I think he
was a completely different
the character had absolutely nothing to
do with the comics but he's the one that
had the idea for organic web shooters
and it just stuck when it came time to
do the Sam Raimi spider-man films so
when they got to the Andrew Garfield
amazing spider-man they went back to
comic book mechanical web-shooters which
I think Bendis actually took credit for
I think he was the one that told them to
go back to mechanical web-shooters later
in the post-credits scene he's playing
with Iron Man's new version of the
mechanical web-shooters
they're just upgraded stark tech he also
like his new suit is kind of like the
iron spider suit of the comics without
the actual
iron in the road to comic book Civil War
spider-man had been living at the
Avengers mansion he had been working
with Tony Stark in the Avengers for a
long time Tony Stark builds him a new
spider-man suit that is based on his
Iron Man suit so he's called the iron
spider during the course of that
storyline spider-man switches from Team
Iron Man to team Captain America goes
back to the old costume but in the
movies here this dark tech costume will
be the costume of the new spider-man
homecoming movie so he'll be wearing
this when you see him again next year
and when he comes back for Avengers
infinity war the Russo said that he will
get another new suit the whole reason
that Iron Man went to him originally
though was to recruit him for his team
to join The Avengers it was kind of like
a tryout there have been a number of
times in the comics when Spiderman was
offered membership in the Avengers he
usually turned them down I mean
eventually he did join the Avengers but
the first big team-up they had was in
1964 came the Conqueror six a robot
Spider Man on the Avengers and they all
have to team up to defeat it the first
time they offered him membership in the
Avengers was in 1966 during amazing
spider-man annual number three so Spider
Man has been teaming up with the
Avengers for a long long time he even
helped fight Thanos in 1977 during
Marvel two and one annual so all the
stuff you see spider-man doing with the
Avengers all the stuff you see him doing
infinity war all very much from comic
book Canon earlier in the film Captain
America discovers that Sharon Carter is
Peggy's niece that's actually true to
the comics originally she was Peggy's
younger sister she's kind of like caps
girlfriend in the comics for a long time
when they got ready to do that that's
when they retcon her backstory and made
her Peggy's niece instead of her younger
sister when we meet Everett
raus everybody knows him his Thunderbolt
Ross he becomes the Red Hulk in the
comics not gonna be happening in the
movies anytime soon but the sokovia
accords is basically a movie version of
the superhero Registration Act the
reason for that in the comics was the
stamford incident the version of that in
the movie is Scarlet Witch accidentally
killing all those wakandans when he says
banner and Thor are missing Thor has
actually gone back to Asgard they'll
address what he's doing during Thor
Ragnarok Hulk is going to be in that
film so they can't find Hulk because
he's on Asgard in real life before they
had started to make civil war Chris
Hemsworth was working on another movie
with Tom Holland who plays spider-man
they had started the audition process
for the new spider-man so Tom Holland on
the set of their other movie ask Chris
Hemsworth to go to the CEO of Disney and
put in a good word for him for the new
spider-man role so spider-man got a
personal recommendation to join the
Avengers from Thor in real life which
actually leads us into Black Panther
stuff so let's talk some Black Panther
Easter eggs when he says death is not
the end for us it's a very literal thing
T'Challa is king of the wakandans but
he's also Black Panther king of the Dead
as in he has access to all the
experience and memories of the previous
Black Panthers so in the comics he can
actually access all of his father's
memories they weren't really clear about
it in the movie but the mantle of Black
Panther in the comics is passed down
from father to son from King to King his
father to Chaka in the movie doesn't
look quite as feral so it's hard to tell
if he had ever been Black Panther in his
past but in the movie two challahs
already black panther usually the mantle
isn't past until the previous Black
Panther dies let's talk about the
villain Baron Zemo in the movie he's
just called Zemo the reason he's pissed
at the Avengers is because his family
died
he's from sokovia he was part of a
sokovia and death squad so yeah it sucks
that his family died but it sounds like
he spent a lot of his time killing other
people so he's not that good of a person
to begin with Baron Zemo is a huge
villain from the comics he forms the
Masters of evil so we might see a
version of that in the movies eventually
they're not Hydra they've effectively
killed off Hydra in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they kind of addressed that on
agents of shield this season so I would
expect all the
big villains in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to come from other non Hydra
places from now on which is kind of nice
I kind of like that they're distancing
themselves from that people had a lot of
questions about zimos plan in the movie
how he was moving pieces around
manipulating the Avengers and show them
the Howard Stark tape of him being
murdered his whole plan was to let Tony
Stark watch this tape that's all he
needed to do so one of the biggest
complaints of the movie and I do think
it's kind of fair is that he didn't just
go straight for the tape and show it to
Iron Man because iron man probably would
have done the same thing in the moment
is actually canon in the comics Winter
Soldier did kill Tony Stark's parents
final fight probably one of the best in
the history of superhero movies but also
very much comic-book canon when he holds
the shield up and Captain America
blasted this is straight from the cover
of civil war there were a couple of
other comic book panel moments like
scenes that looked exactly like comic
book covers when ant-man turns into
giant man and grabs war machines foot
and just kind of holds him out here like
this there was even a time during comic
book civil war when Spiderman got his
hands on Captain America's shield and I
know a lot of people were disappointed
that the actual other winter soldiers
didn't turn into a real thing they were
just kind of a MacGuffin there is a
what-if comic book that says what if
Captain America had led a super soldier
army into world war two in that story a
bunch of US allies get turned into super
soldiers they absolutely destroy Hydra
in that continuity Falcon also gets to
be giant man so nicely straig because
Falcon and Ant Man have so much history
in the movies everybody probably spotted
the Empire Strikes Back reference in the
Easter Egg for the 8080 takedown I guess
that makes spider-man Luke Skywalker he
kind of is Luke Skywalker in this movie
at the end of the film when Captain
America breaks all the other Avengers
out of the raft which is also an Easter
Egg for the comics the raft is like a
secret floating Supermax for all the
worst villains Captain America breaks
them out in the movie if you guys read
the Dark Reign storyline what happens is
Norman Osborn becomes the new face of
the Avengers in the government like this
government-led Avengers team so Captain
America has to assemble a Secret
Avengers team and there was a storyline
called Secret Avengers
that's what caps talking about when he
says anytime you need me Tony just call
and gives him that secret phone because
Ironman
can't roll the Avengers out whenever he
wants to now and if it wasn't clear at
the end of the film as Tony Stark is
reading that letter cap is telling him
he doesn't hold a grudge it's not like
they're best friends again but they do
have a mutual respect for each other
Tony probably resents his actions and he
still hasn't completely processed all
the grief about his parents dying in all
the regrets for the things that he did
not do he never got a chance to make
things right with his parents before
they died just like spider-man and Uncle
Ben so spider-man's stark Tech at the
end of the film is just to show you that
you were going to see Iron Man during
spider-man's film I think that his
relationship with spider-man is gonna be
a really positive influence on him it'll
be a way for him to work through his
grief he'll be something of a surrogate
father figure to spider-man but the
other thing that I think is going on in
this post credits scene when Aunt May is
asking him about the people that punched
him in the face oh you should have seen
one of them he was huge and she's kind
of like is there anything else that you
want to tell me and smiles at him I
think what's going on here is that she
knows that he's spider-man and is just
letting him think that he's keeping the
secret there's this whole thing about
smart women in the Marvel Universe like
Pepper Potts way smarter than she
pretends to be so I think the same
things going on with Aunt May Aunt May
knows that Peter Parker spider-man and
she's just being really cool letting him
think that he's keeping the secret but
I'm also kind of wondering if Black
Panther now is going to be funding
Captain America's Secret Avengers but I
think the Tony Stark will also help them
out too because like I said even though
they're not best friends
Iron Man still recognizes what Captain
America is doing is the right thing so I
think he's gonna try and help him out
too so even though the Avengers broke up
Zemo is still alive they've all kind of
made nice so like all the heroes will
still be able to work together in future
films they just won't be hugging each
other all the time but let me know what
was your favorite Easter Egg for the
film was that a man riding Hawkeye zero
was a giant man was it all the
spider-man stuff there's just so much in
this movie I'm gonna have to see it
three or four more times there's
probably a whole bunch of Easter eggs
that I've missed if there's any that you
spotted that I didn't mention just write
them below in the comments and giveaway
time congratulations to the Captain
America giveaway winner Brian Brooks you
went to IMAX gift certificates just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details that's on the about page
and Deadpool giveaway winner if you guys
didn't know I was running a dead
we'll give away congratulations to hugo
johansson you win a copy of the Deadpool
DVD also be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel for
contact details I'm probably gonna do at
least a couple more civil war videos so
I'll start a new round of the giveaway
the next time I post one while you guys
wait for me to post my next video you
can click here for my Civil War review
video and you can click here to start
getting ready for a game of Thrones this
weekend thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight